ce sont deux classes de première du
lycée jean vilar qui ont pu écouter le
parcours d'une écrivaine ce dispositif
appelé leçon de littérature est proposée
par la région ile de france c'est la
quatrième année que celui ci y
participent aux élèves c'est une grande
chance de rencontrer un auteur d'écouté
parcours d'un auteur est alors
j'ajouterai que cette année c'était
encore mieux encore plus important pour
les élèves en cette période convient aux
pattes cinéma théâtre et cette année
c'est l'auteur clémentine meslois qui a
partagé aux élèves son univers ses
lectures et son travail d'écriture
c'est surtout que c'est pas un cours de
français donc j'ai beaucoup plus de
liberté que les professeurs de français
qui suivent un programme et qui sont qui
mettent des notes
là c'est surtout un échange et c'est une
parole très informel où je parle
simplement de ma façon à moi de ton
visage est mon métier
la façon que je le vis en fait
l'écrivaine fait partie d'un groupe de
travail qui s'appelle l'oulipo ouvroir
de littérature potentielle objectif
écrire avec des contraintes et jouer
avec les mots ce style d'écriture à
intéresser les jeunes lycéens
je connaissais pas vraiment le goût
lipow et bah j'en ai appris plus
justement sur sa sur des nouvelles
manières de décrire son idée de
détourner des nombreux romans j'ai
trouvé ça sympathique avec les milles de
course si ces tests est rigolo comme l
inventer une vie
à des personnages à partir de la liste
de courses l'auteur était à une manière
particulière d'écrire on a pu voir du
coup un livre au cdi sur les jumeaux
qu'elle faisait sur la volonté de ses
oeuvres
je trouve ça intéressant de novembre
2020 à mai 2021 ce seront plus de onze
mille lycéens franciliens qui
bénéficieront de ces leçons de
littérature